Thomas Stocker
ist derzeit ein gefragter Mann.
Denn es gab einen Rekordsommer.
Und das Thema Klimawandel
ist in aller Munde.
Das ist der drittwärmste Sommer
seit 1864.
In dieser Häufung
ist das ganz klar eine Auswirkung
des menschengemachten Klimawandels.
* Beschwingte Xylofonklänge *
Klimaforscher
denken in Jahrhunderten,
Medien berichten
über Einzelereignisse.
Stocker und seine Kollegen
sollen dann jeweils erklären,
wie es so weit kommen konnte -
und wie es weitergeht.
Kein Zufall also,
dass Stockers erster Auftritt
im Schweizer Fernsehen 1995 war -
ein Jahr
nach dem Rekordsommer von 1994.
(Originalton) Stürme werden heftiger
und Gewitter entladen sich
immer früher im Jahr.
Am stärksten leiden
bei uns die Bergregionen.
Erdrutsche und Murgänge sind
die Folgen abschmelzender Gletscher
und auftauender Dauerfrosthänge -
Folgen der zunehmenden Erwärmung.
(Originalton)
1994 war das heisseste Jahr,
das in der Schweiz
jemals registriert worden ist.
Die Temperaturen
lagen je nach Region
bis zu 3 °C über dem Durchschnitt.
(Originalton) Die Klimaforscher am
Physikalischen Institut der Uni Bern
sind weltweit führend.
Wie interpretiert Professor
Thomas Stocker die Wetteranomalien?
Die Kenntnisse der Physik
und der Biologie des Klimasystems
machen es sehr wahrscheinlich,
dass solche Extremereignisse
und ihre Häufung
mit menschengemachten
Klimaveränderungen
verknüpft sein könnten.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Heute ist Stocker
einer der weltweit renommiertesten
und einflussreichsten Klimaforscher.
Er ist
an die Ostküste Grönlands gereist:
nach Ilulissat, wo über den Aufbau
eines internationalen
Forschungs-Hubs diskutiert wird.
Wer Klimaforschung
auf internationalem Spitzenniveau
betreiben wolle,
der brauche politischen Goodwill,
Geld und Zugang zu Grönland,
sagt Stocker.
(Englisch) Hier ist der Hotspot
der Forschung zum Klimawandel.
Wir wollen die Dynamik
und das Schicksal dieses Eisschildes
verstehen.
Neben Klimaforschern sind
auch Diplomaten des EDA angereist.
Die Politik profitiert
von Wissenschaftlern wie Stocker.
Die Spitzenforschung
öffnet der Politik Türen.
Etwa zum Arktischen Rat,
einem Forum bestehend aus
den Anrainerstaaten des Nordpols,
darunter die USA und Russland.
Das EDA
spricht von Wissenschaftsdiplomatie.
Einerseits
möchte man Politik betreiben,
die stärker durch die Wissenschaft
und durch Fakten inspiriert ist,
damit man anhand wissenschaftlicher
Forschung und Erkenntnisse
entscheiden kann,
welche Politik man betreiben muss.
Andererseits - und das ist
vielleicht fast noch interessanter -
überlegt man sich,
wie man Wissenschaft
als Hintertürchen benutzen kann,
um Leute an einen Tisch zu bringen,
die selten miteinander reden
und selten am selben Tisch sitzen.
Darum wird hier
auch auf Stocker angestossen.
Unter Klimaforschern
ist der 59-jährige Vater von zwei
erwachsenen Töchtern unumstritten,
für sog. Klimakritiker
indes eine Reizfigur.
Dass es wärmer wird,
bestreitet niemand.
Dass CO2 einen Einfluss
auf die Erderwärmung hat,
bestreitet auch niemand.
- Ach ja?
Es besteht ja ein absoluter Konsens.
- Tatsächlich?
Die Frage ist nur,
wie gross dieser Einfluss ist
und ob er in diesem Sinne
katastrophisch ist.
Und diesbezüglich
erlaube ich mir einen Rat an Sie,
obwohl ich der Jüngere bin.
Im "Weltwoche"-Interview sagen Sie:
"Der Klimawandel ist
das grösste Problem der Gegenwart."
Da geben Sie sich doch eine Blösse.
Sie geben sich als Kämpfer
und Aktivist zu erkennen. - Nein.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Der Satz "Der Klimawandel ist
eine der grössten Herausforderungen
der Menschheit"
steht in der Klimakonvention.
Das sagt sie auch, ja.
Ich darf doch noch
aus der Klimakonvention zitieren ...
Erlauben Sie mir nochmals ...
... zu der alle Staaten
dieses Planeten stehen.
Das ist so, wie wenn ich nicht
aus der "Weltwoche" zitieren dürfte.
Auch für den Bauingenieur
und Architekten Paul Bossert
ist Stocker ein rotes Tuch.
2007 fuhr Bossert nach Deutschland
und traf sich in einer Autobahn-
raststätte namens Heiligenroth
mit einer Gruppe Gleichgesinnter:
alles Zweifler,
die meisten Naturwissenschaftler.
Für sie war erwiesen,
dass Klimaerwärmung und CO2
nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
... noch mehr
über die Sache herausbringen.
Ich denke, wir müssen gegen
diese Propaganda falscher Daten
und falscher Zahlen vorgehen,
die sich zu einer politischen
Ideologie hochstilisiert hat.
Der Schlusspunkt
war die Formulierung eines Manifests.
Die Teilnehmer
rangen um die richtigen Worte.
Es geht ja um die Frage, ob
der Mensch das Klima schützen kann.
Richtig, das ist die wichtige Frage.
- Das ist das eine.
Das Wort "Klimaschutz" ...
Man kann kein Klima schützen.
Ja, genau,
das Klima kann man nicht schützen.
Das ist das Fazit.
- Das Fazit?
Ja.
- Das Fazit.
Das Klimamanifest von Heiligenroth
gibt es noch immer.
Bossert feiert seinen Achtzigsten
und ist überzeugter denn je,
dass uns die Klimaforscher
an der Nase herumführen.
Ab 1980 studierte ich an der ETH.
Ich habe Bauchemie,
Bauphysik und das Klima studiert
und merkte dabei,
dass keine Theorie funktioniert.
Die Ursache des Klimawandels,
behauptet sie locker,
sei das CO2,
und das haut mich vom Hocker.
Wieso sehen das denn
die meisten Klimaforscher anders?
Das sind keine Klimaforscher,
sondern Behaupter.
Thomas Stocker ist z.B. einer,
der einfach etwas behauptet.
Auch die Leute von der ETH Zürich
behaupten einfach etwas
und können es nicht belegen.
Es gibt keinen
physikalischen Effekt, der zeigt,
dass die Änderung der Konzentration
des Spurengases
z.B. die Temperatur eines
bodennahen Gasbereichs verändert.
Diesen sog. atmosphärischen
Treibhauseffekt gibt es also nicht.
Diese Behauptung sei durch Tausende
von wissenschaftlichen Studien
klar widerlegt, sagt Stocker.
Eine weitere Diskussion
sei reine Zeitverschwendung.
Stocker studierte
an der ETH Zürich Umweltphysik
und legte eine steile Karriere hin.
Er wurde Professor an der Uni Bern
und eine prägende Figur
im Weltklimarat,
einem Gremium der UNO, das sich u.a.
mit den Folgen globaler Erwärmung
für Umwelt und Gesellschaft befasst.
Da die Berichte des Weltklimarates
die Grundlage
für die globale Klimapolitik sind,
sein Einfluss also enorm ist,
werden an ihn höchste
ethische Anforderungen gestellt.
Ich interessierte mich
für viele Dinge,
aber während des Gymnasiums
wurde mir klar,
dass mich die Natur
sehr stark interessiert,
v.a. physikalische und mathematische
Methoden als Instrumente,
um das Verständnis für die Natur
zu erzeugen.
Das faszinierte mich immer.
Fantastisch!
- (Mann) Noch schnell ein Selfie.
* Lachen *
Den aktuellen Vorsitzenden
des Weltklimarates
beurteilt Stocker kritisch.
(Französisch) Man dachte,
das sei eine Funktion mit einem
starken wissenschaftlichen Element.
Aber man sah,
dass es immer politischer wurde.
Die ganze Klimadebatte auch.
Das ist
eine sehr sichtbare Position,
wenn man sie denn sichtbar macht.
Pachauri machte sie sichtbar.
Aber er ist über Dummheiten
und Vorwürfe gestolpert.
Die Rede ist von Rajendra Pachauri,
dem Ex-Chef des Weltklimarates,
und von Vorwürfen
sexueller Belästigung.
Der IPCC
brauchte einen neuen Vorsitzenden.
Stocker war der wissenschaftlich
kompetenteste Kandidat.
Gewählt
wurde der Südkoreaner Hoesung Lee.
(Französisch) Die Südkoreaner
haben diese Wahl gewonnen.
Denn sie haben bei ihrer Kampagne
ein bisschen nachgeholfen.
Gekaufte Stimmen
bei der Wahl des IPCC-Vorsitzes?
Vor malerischer Kulisse
platzt eine Bombe.
Ich will es genauer wissen.
Das EDA lieferte viel Unterstützung.
Aber die Wahl
ging trotzdem verloren,
weil ein anderes Land, Südkorea ...
... völlig andere
zusätzliche Mittel einsetzte,
um diese Wahl zu gewinnen.
Welche denn?
Ich denke, Südkorea versprach
einigen Ländern direkte Hilfen,
um Stimmen zu gewinnen.
Jedes Land hat ja eine Stimme
in einer UNO-Wahl
für eine solche Position.
Ich glaube, es gab direkte Kontakte
zwischen den höchsten Stellen
dieser Länder,
um diese Stimmen zu sichern.
* Möwenrufe *
Ein IPCC-Insider
bestätigt gegenüber "Reporter":
Südkorea habe sich die Wahl
tatsächlich etwas kosten lassen.
Der IPCC teilt schriftlich mit:
Die Wahl sei
nach den IPCC-Richtlinien abgelaufen
und das Ergebnis
von allen Ländern akzeptiert worden.
Zurück in der Schweiz hat Stocker
seine Ansicht nicht geändert.
Wie qualifizieren Sie das?
Geld gegen Stimmen
könnte man Korruption nennen, oder?
Diesen Aspekt hat es.
Es wird natürlich schwierig,
die unabhängige
wissenschaftliche Arbeit zu leisten,
die der Weltklimarat im Auftrag
aller Länder durchführen muss.
Wenn einzelne Länder
eine Verpflichtung gegenüber
dem Vorsitzenden geltend machen,
wird es sehr schwierig.
Der IPCC verzichtet
auf eine weitere Stellungnahme.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Bellen eines Hundes *
Zurück in Grönland,
wo Stockers Reise noch weiterging.
Auf Einladung von Christiane Leister,
einer vermögenden Unternehmerin.
Sie offerierte einer Gruppe
bestehend aus Wissenschaftlern,
Diplomaten und Künstlern
eine All-Inclusive-Expedition.
Ziel: sich vor Ort
über den Klimawandel informieren
und das Erlebte weitertragen.
Seine Lebensumstände
hätten sich in den vergangenen Jahren
spürbar verändert, erzählt ein Jäger.
Das Eis
ziehe sich immer weiter zurück,
das mache das Jagen
immer schwieriger.
Er führt die Gruppe zum Hafen -
und zu dem, was von den gestern
erlegten Narwalen übrig ist.
Noch hätten sie genug zu essen,
aber er glaube,
dass die Folgen des Klimawandels
existenzbedrohend werden könnten.
Bei uns zweifeln indes weiter viele.
Nur 44 % der Schweizer glauben, dass
der Klimawandel menschgemacht ist.
Daraus könnte man noch
ein paar Handschuhe anfertigen.
Bei vielen
geht es um verspieltes Vertrauen.
Immer wieder
fällt das Stichwort Waldsterben,
ein Phänomen der 1980er-Jahre.
(Originalton) Es begann,
erinnert sich
Kantonsoberförster George Gerig,
mit massenhaft
absterbenden Weisstannen
im unteren Bereich des Bannwaldes.
Seit zwei Jahren häufen sich
nun auch die Schadenbilder
an der Fichte in den Höhenlagen.
Wir erschraken
bereits dieses Jahr sehr stark.
Ich war auch mit Fachleuten hier,
die es vollkommen bestätigten.
Panik machte sich breit.
(Mann) Wenn nicht ganz rigorose
Massnahmen ergriffen werden,
kann es tatsächlich
zu einer Katastrophe kommen.
Wenn der Wald
wirklich gestorben ist,
haben wir auf der Welt
auch nicht mehr viel zu suchen.
Es ist fünf nach zwölf.
Die heraufbeschworene Katastrophe
blieb allerdings aus.
Das Problem des Schwefels im Diesel
und ...
... beim Verbrennen von Erdöl
bekam man in den Griff,
indem man den Schwefel entfernte,
einen Reinigungsschritt vornahm.
Dadurch erholten sich die Wälder.
Das ist kein Mythos.
Es war damals sicher ...
- Übertrieb man damals nicht?
In der Schweiz wurde es sicher
etwas zu dramatisch dargestellt,
das muss man zugeben.
Aber man muss auch festhalten ...
... das Klimasystem der Welt
ist beinahe einfacher zu verstehen
und zu quantifizieren als ein Wald.
Es gibt viel mehr ...
- Das müssen Sie erklären.
Es gibt viel mehr Messungen.
Es gibt Temperaturmessungen,
und in der ganzen Atmosphäre,
im weltweiten Ozean
gibt es Messungen
bezüglich der letzten 60 Jahre.
Damit können wir genau festhalten,
wie sich das Umweltsystem
im globalen Massstab veränderte -
über viele Jahrzehnte hinweg.
Wir verstehen
die physikalischen Prozesse.
Wir besitzen Modelle,
mit denen wir sie nachbilden können.
Auf dieser wissenschaftlichen Basis
haben wir viel mehr Informationen
als damals über
das relativ komplexe Ökosystem Wald,
das noch viele Unbekannte hatte.
Stockers Reisegruppe
nutzt den freien Nachmittag für einen
Augenschein im lokalen Supermarkt.
Im Sortiment sind Hundeschlitten ...
... die neuesten iPhones ...
... Zehenwärmer ...
... und Alkoholika.
Kurz: was der Grönländer
zwischen Tradition und Moderne
offenbar so braucht.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Wir fliegen in zwei Charter-
flugzeugen Richtung Norden.
Unser Ziel: eine internationale
Forschungsstation namens EastGRIP.
Ich wähne mich
auf einem fernen Eisplaneten:
surreal, wunderschön -
und bitter kalt: -25 °C.
Wegen des Windes ist die gefühlte
Temperatur allerdings tiefer: -38 °C.
* Pfeifen des Windes *
Stocker und sein Team
modellieren vergangene
und künftige Klimaveränderungen.
Eisbohrkerne aus Grönland
liefern ihnen dafür die Basis.
Mit speziellen Bohrern
dringen die Forscher
bis zu 3 km ins Eisschild vor.
Sie fördern Eis,
das über 100'000 Jahre alt ist.
Das Ergebnis sieht dann so aus:
Wunderbar.
Sie legten ihn einfach
zu Demonstrationszwecken hier hin.
Die Bohrkerne werden gelagert
und später
u.a an die Uni Bern verschickt.
Das ist ein einmaliges Klimaarchiv.
Hier messen wir
über 60 verschiedene Grössen,
entweder am Eis oder an der Luft,
die im Eis eingeschlossen ist.
Damit kann man eine einzigartige
Klimageschichte schreiben.
In Grönland
können wir uns etwa 100'000 Jahre
in die Vergangenheit begeben.
Man kann die Zusammensetzung
der Atmosphäre,
die Konzentration der Treibhausgase
und sogar
die natürlichen Klimaschwankungen
und die Klimavariabilität
anhand dieser Eisbohrkernen messen.
Das ist ein einmaliges Klimaarchiv,
das diese Informationen enthält.
Aber wie zuverlässig
sind die darauf basierenden Modelle?
2007 gab sich Stocker selbstbewusst.
Es gibt sicher irgendwann wieder ein
Jahr, das kein Rekordwärmejahr ist,
aber die Tendenz steigt ganz klar,
wie wir in den letzten zwölf Jahren
feststellten.
Dann wurde es immer offensichtlicher,
dass die Temperaturen
nicht mehr wie vorausgesagt stiegen.
1998 hatte
eine sog. Klimapause eingesetzt.
Die Temperatur sei stagniert.
Wie passt das jetzt zusammen?
Man darf die Dinge
nicht verwechseln:
Es ist ein langfristiger Trend.
Seit Ende des 19. Jh. erwärmte sich
die Erde um knapp 1 °C.
Die 15 Jahre, die wir betrachten,
haben nichts mit diesem lang-
anhaltenden Erwärmungstrend zu tun.
Sie wurden
durch natürliche Schwankungen
und Einflussgrössen wie die Sonne
oder die Staubbelastung
in der Atmosphäre verursacht.
Ganz verstanden haben wir diese
Phänomene allerdings noch nicht.
Kurz darauf dann die Erlösung
für Stocker: wieder ein Rekordjahr.
Waren Sie froh, als es
endlich wieder etwas wärmer wurde?
Ja, da sagte ich:
"Jawohl, wir hatten recht."
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Die Reise geht weiter und weiter -
und noch weiter.
Wir landen an immer ferneren Orten.
Unbezahlbare Erlebnisse,
bleibende Eindrücke.
Auf Einladung der passionierten
Heli-Skifahrerin Christiane Leister.
Und sehr CO2-intensiv.
Zumal für eine Gruppe,
die der Gesellschaft vermitteln will,
sie möge sich im Interesse der Natur
doch bitte einschränken.
Wir haben natürlich
auch darüber nachgedacht.
Es ist klar, dass
die ganze Reise kompensiert wird.
D.h., wir investieren in dem Mass,
in dem wir für C02-Ausstoss sorgten,
in Projekte,
die den CO2-Ausstoss reduzieren.
Das ist ein bisschen ein
Ablasshandel. Wer soll denn sparen?
V.a. diejenigen, die sich
die Zertifikate nicht leisten können?
Das ist ein langsamer Übergang.
Momentan gibt es
keine andere Möglichkeit,
als solche Zertifikate oder
solche Projekte zu unterstützen,
wenn man mit dem Flugzeug
unterwegs ist.
Natürlich besteht die Möglichkeit,
gar nicht zu fliegen.
Haben Sie
ein gewisses Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem?
Nein, wenn wir meine Arbeit
hier in den Polargebieten
oder im Weltklimarat,
wo wir sehr viel herumreisten,
mit Zertifikaten oder den Projekten,
die wir unterstützen, kompensieren
und uns überlegen,
wozu diese Arbeit dient,
ist das
kein Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem.
Mit anderen Worten:
Der Zweck, in diesem Falle
die Wissenschaft, heiligt die Mittel.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Aber war Stocker wirklich zu einem
wissenschaftlichen Zweck unterwegs?
Ja, sagt er, wir seien z.B. in der
Forschungsstation EastGRIP gewesen.
Dort konnten wir mit den Kollegen
ein Gespräch über den Stand
des Projekts führen.
Sie hätten auch anrufen können, oder?
Ja, aber ein persönlicher Besuch
bei denjenigen,
die vor Ort als Partner
in diesem Projekt arbeiten,
hat auch eine wichtige
persönliche Komponente.
Könnte man sagen, dass es
nicht nur um Wissenschaft ging,
sondern auch um Lobbying?
Einerseits um politisches
und andererseits
um finanzielles Lobbying,
damit sich Frau Leister mit Geld
an Ihrer Forschung beteiligt?
Überhaupt nicht.
Ich hatte
nebst den wissenschaftlichen
allerdings noch zwei weitere Ziele.
Das erste Ziel war, mit dänischen
Wissenschaftlern und Administratoren
über die Möglichkeit zu sprechen,
einen Science-Hub aufzubauen.
Das war ein interessantes Seminar
in Ilulissat.
Der zweite Punkt war,
durch die persönliche Begegnung
mit der Bevölkerung
in den verschiedenen Dörfern
zu sehen,
wie sich der Klimawandel
direkt auf die Menschen auswirkt,
die hier oben leben.
Und ich frage mich, wie es
mit dem grossen Ganzen weitergeht:
mit der Welt,
mit dem Klima und mit uns allen.